alright guys here we go we've got
Frankie scoops in the house today so
let's let's just get this thing popping
right off the start
thank you for coming so much yeah no
worries pleasure to be here we have gone
back and forth on Twitter way too much
first time meeting in person
you've got more energy in real life than
on Twitter so I'm excited about this big
scoop energy that's what they call me
alright so let's go through your
background most people don't know that
how young you are and kind of how you
got into the media side of crypto yeah I
am pretty young which is surprising
because of all of my mannerisms that
would otherwise otherwise suggest that
I'm like 67 years old but it all started
in college at wfu v I got into radio got
into telling stories got into the news
first in politics so going down to City
Hall writing up stories on really
pedantic City Hall type things that
really start to bore me after a while
and I found a respite and writing about
business news and there's less sort of
vitriol in business news in a sense and
it's funny that I ended up finding my
way to crypto because there's tons of
vitriol and crypto but the thing that I
liked about business was it was a lot
less bullcrap in a sense a lot less
fighting back and forth a lot more
building things and figuring out how we
can build things that that people want
to buy and so I ended up finding myself
at Nasdaq as a marketing corporate
communications intern really learned
about capital markets for the first time
market formation market structure
initial public offerings the stock
market all those things that I really
hadn't been exposed to in my studies
because I was studying theology and sort
of international political economy and I
fell in love with the best part of my
job when I was marketing at Nasdaq
wasn't necessarily the job itself but
waking up in the morning reading The
Wall Street Journal listening to
Bloomberg radio and after that was done
I decided this is what I want to do I
want to tell stories that will you know
make an impact on Wall Street and in the
business
world and had a great opportunity to
intern at BI which started out basically
they threw me you know they threw me
into the Wolves den covering whatever I
wanted talking entrepreneurs I think
because of my sort of demeanor as a 60
year old trapped in a 23 year old body
or a 23 year old trapped in a 60 year
old body thank god this is podcast and
not television because I have the face
for the for the former and I really was
able to build a name for myself and
quickly after a couple months and
especially after they brought me on
full-time I mean I was talking to people
like the president of the New York Stock
Exchange and the president rather the
founder of IX and massively important
folks on Wall Street and it wasn't until
I came on full-time that they sort of
said alright we need someone to write
about this Bitcoin thing and I said
Bitcoin crypto I mean I want to be taken
seriously as a financial journalist and
I want to write about magic internet
money all day yep and their response
basically was well you're gonna be
writing about magic internet money all
day because the things exploding this
was right around May 2017 right after
I'd graduated from Fordham and they
needed someone to really pick up the
coverage because the thing was exploding
as far as impressions were concerned in
terms of the editors asking questions
you know I remember someone came to me
at Business Insider at the time and said
what is a theorem we need someone to
write about what a theorem is because
the the Google trend traffic is is off
the charts and it was at the
off-the-charts if you remember you know
it's down now along with the price and
so really just dove into the thing and
and the rest is sort of history but it
was really accidental in a sense being
at the right place at the right time and
it was over the course of the next I'd
say six months as the thing exploded was
finding in each at the intersection of
this crazy crypto world and Wall Street
what are the people on Wall Street doing
and at the time they really
under plate it so we're talking
September October November right around
the time when Jamie Dimon called this
thing a fad right I was thinking all
right but what are they doing with it
and I thought the place that made the
most sense to go to were the exchanges
because when we think about blockchain
technology and where it can have the
biggest impact obviously on capital
formation so the IPO process could be
disrupted by something like an ICO or an
IEEE security token offering an sto and
obviously trading can be impacting you
have things like decentralized exchanges
that supplement matching bringing
together by bringing together buyers and
sellers and so I wanted to see if they
were positioning themselves places like
Nuys e Nasdaq CBO a CMA how they were
positioning themselves to take advantage
and monetize this this revolution in a
sense and at the time I mean no one
really they didn't seem like they had an
idea right we're looking at it we're
thinking about it we look at all
technologies but really I mean now we
know a year later right where they were
all in they were all in and they were
all in for a while right and so at the
time when I when I was thinking about
the impact that futures could have
Bitcoin futures on the market I went to
all the analysts who cover the exchanges
so you know the the investment bank or
the investment bankers who are writing
up stock report analysts for their you
know asset management clients to see how
they can you know the ones that set the
price targets right yep your listeners
who might not understand what what
investment bankers some of them do and I
went to them and said listen what do you
think the revenue opportunity is here
Bank of America put out a report at the
time this was around November October
that said that one Bitcoin futures could
help dampen volatility which kind of
didn't really happen if you think about
it but also there was a ten percent
revenue something for exchanges so I
went to other folks covering the stock
and they had not only did they really
not understand what Wayne was but they
hung up the phone on me they said this
is ridiculous
the exchanges aren't going to do
anything in this space I don't see what
the opportunity is here how off they
were here we are now with back with act
with with Nasdaq potentially looking to
do something with cryptocurrency
exchanges
they're supplying a market surveillance
technology to I think at this point five
cryptocurrency firms and so it really is
a horse of a different color and and to
really bring the point home of how much
it's changed since I first started
covering it I remember asking a year ago
a very high up executive at one of the
exchanges how big of an opportunity that
is this and and basically he echoed the
same thing that Jamie Dimon said it's a
fad it's dangerous here we are now here
we know that they're only they're all in
yeah yeah so okay so let's talk about
you know the state of the media encrypt
that right so I kind of bucket it in a
couple of different categories so you've
got kind of legacy media which is CNBC
Bloomberg you know mainstream media
etcetera then you've got what I would
consider crypto specific media which is
the you know coin desks the you know CC
ends coin telegraphic cetera and then
you have this like citizen journal
journalists right which are like all the
people on Twitter reddit medium etc that
are basically reporting the ground truth
how do you see those three interacting
and like what is the state of each one
of them well I think it's interesting
because as far as legacy media is
concerned I think there are so many
topics that journalists have to cover
that it really just does become about
the price and how traditional
institutions are viewing this space
right and it's all sort of in that lens
which under serves a lot of the folks
who have been in it for a really long
time since you know 2008 since the
beginning or maybe since 2012 and so
that in and of itself you know up until
I'd say year ago where you have some
really fine journalists at places like
Bloomberg and Business Insider and and
in the New York Times up until a year
ago most of the stories either had to do
with price or the culture of these
for punks etc that's changed and I think
we've seen a lot of legging meet like
legacy media really dive into this and
and pick apart issues ranging from
technology trading and others but that
gap from the beginning where a lot of
this was sort of viewed as a
fly-by-night sort of thing allowed for a
lot of these medium type folks to come
up a lot of vloggers a lot of podcasters
a lot of writers who are also trading
this stuff and and investing in this
stuff
to fill a gap and really get granular on
the technology side and I think now you
have all well you have those types of
folks along with traditional media but
at the same time and this is a recent
phenomenon to a Cambrian explosion if
you will of crypto media publications
you know that to be honest and to be
frank no pun intended
the pun was very much intended there are
a lot of these crypto publications that
don't know how journalism works they
don't know how sourcing works and
there's a lot that I think you know I'm
very skeptical of who these crypto first
publications outside of coin desk I mean
they have great folks working on great
stories but outside of that I'm very
skeptical of where they're getting their
information of from and and the due
diligence they're doing to really make
sure the information they have is
precise and well source you know so
let's talk about this dough right a
bunch of us on Twitter have lovingly
started calling you Frankie scoops right
yeah because you continue to publish
scoop after scoop after scoop as my ego
grows and grows and grows but but let's
walk through like the anatomy of a scoop
right how do you show we go through one
that you help me with so let's talk like
how you find sources right how do you
actually develop that source learn to
trust them get information from them and
eventually publish something well that
was the best thing right about the
intersection that I was at no one in
well I don't want to say no one cuz
that's a blanket statement but very few
journalists I think we're actually
looking at well let's talk to the market
structure crypto expert at this Wall
Street firm as opposed to you know the
crypto first firms like you know block
block chain or you know a circle or a or
a coin base I thought let me go to the
chicago-based market making firms New
York Stock Exchange let me find their
Bitcoin guys their crypto guys because
no one's probably really talking to them
because the attention is all on the
crypto side the crypto first side of
things and so that's really your
approach was let me go to the
established legacy players the Wall
street-type institutions and if I start
there it's kind of a trickle down from
you know the well-established well known
players all the way down to the
individual startups and that's exactly
what happens so I started with like you
know let's say the head of digital
assets at X Wall Street firm and they
were able to connect me and grow my base
with actually the crypto first guy so I
started at Wall Street and then exactly
as you sort of described branch my way
branch myself out to those other folks
and so it's all about I mean the
question is you know how do you build
trust how do you make sure folks know
that you're not going to burn them and
that you're not going to I mean it's
very easy right you know to talk to a
journalist in one sense but but it's a
scary thing you know you don't want to
lose your job and you just need to make
sure that you know I need to make sure
that the person I'm talking to knows
that they can trust me and then I'm not
gonna one tell them tell people things
that they tell me off the record or on
on deep background I'm not going to
associate it with them and it's about
relationships and friendships and
getting to know them on a personal level
going out for a cup of coffee or a or a
drink of some sort and really forming a
relationship of shared information you
know I know things about about the
industry have some insights yet I might
call them insights that can help them at
their job and so it's just like let's
say you call a head of digital at a bank
or wherever
call your asking questions you know that
you want answers to that you can then
use as information for a story or is it
more of hey call them up I want to get
to know you I think that we can build
this long-lasting relationship okay you
don't want to just call them and be like
hey listen I know you're building this
thing you got to tell me everything you
know about it that's gonna scare them
right you know you kind of want to
grease the wheels you'll foot in the
door phenomenon you know how the wife
and kids you know I mean I'm being
tongue-in-cheek but it's it's serious
that's part of that's part of the
process and and so a lot of the time I
hear something from someone like Anthony
pompe Liana my such and such as building
is being built at X company and I think
hmm that's interesting I can't just go
write the story right because Anthony
might not know what the hell he's
talking about you're gonna you're gonna
make me lose all of my friends
everything raised right now Anthony's
not that helpful don't on so it's when
you call these people though because
this is important part right so you call
them and you get information sure how do
you know that the information is true
and do you have to go get it from
multiple people to confirm it or how
does that process or the first thing I
think about when I go into any call
right is why would they tell me this and
how do they potentially benefit from
telling me this yep so I'll give you an
example and this is I think I can give
this example so when I broke that CBOE
was really getting close to or at least
telling its market making clients that
it was getting close to launching ether
futures yep I mean I knew this was
something that would move the price and
so the first market maker who told me
right I'm thinking huh well I they want
to tell me this maybe they have amassed
a large position in aetherium yep and
they would benefit from such a story and
so I think a lot of people in the crypto
world don't think that really good
journalists think about these questions
they just want to get the story out but
this is something that's really really
important to me and so guess so
just because such-and-such market maker
told me that this was something that
they had told him or her I didn't go off
of just that one source and because of
those questions that you have to think
about and so I went to another one got
the same exact story all the details
need to line up because imprecision even
if it's a sentence can radically change
a story and radically can impact
someone's money and you know no one gets
a story right all the time I reported it
was a really gang Buster report on
fidelity and their crypto efforts and
everyone knows that Abigail Johnston's
really big into crypto I had first
reported they were hiring from internal
and this is this is you know when folks
send me stuff from inside the company it
makes the story process so easier
because it's just you look at the
documents you read it and you write it
up and so it's like you have you've got
paper evidence yeah paper evidence that
makes it great cuz you know I don't have
to I can't point to my nameless source I
can just point to what I have in my hand
and so the the job ads basically said
we're hiring for crypto custody and and
for a for projects related to digital
asset exchange yep so I followed up that
report because obviously people when you
put something out like that they want to
talk to you or they want to give you
more information of the story and so I
found out basically that um they had a
VC prop fund under a british subsidiary
from which a number of folks or that was
created by a number of folks at the firm
who had left and i'm sure a lot of your
listeners knew know who these folks are
Castle island ventures and so basically
from I think I talked to you at least
five or six people for this story I mean
I really wanted to make sure I was
getting it right because this isn't
something that fidelity wants to talk
about you know companies typically don't
want to talk about things and companies
typically only want to tell you what
they want to talk about which is the
hardest part of the job and so the the
mistake I made right was that I had
reported that the fund had shot which
was the language that was used by all my
sources
now fidelity calls me the next day and
basically says the fund is inactive now
it kind of sounds like the same thing
right yep but it's that sort of
precision that as a journalist you know
you don't always get it but you want to
get it every single time because the
difference there is shut means is
inactive in perpetuity ready sure sure
the inactive could mean we have money
still sitting here we're not currently
deploying it but we may restart at some
point exactly which is an important
distinction and you know as a journalist
you know you're not always going to get
it a hundred percent right but those are
the questions and those are the those
are the details very specific details
that you always want to go after and so
a long way of answering your question
but tying back to crypto first media and
a lot of the coin desk wannabes of the
world are not I think precisely tackling
stories in that way or they're thinking
about how they may be approaching it in
a way that doesn't get at those tiny
details that at the end of every show
seems super tiny but make a huge
difference on the impact so let me ask
this question um does anyone ever lie to
you
like the horror story right of your
you've got a source you've put some
trust with them they say hey Frank you
know I've got this awesome piece of
information and they lie obviously that
typically doesn't happen so it's not the
folks that I've had established really
great relationships with who will like
me maybe they're they're just confused
you know yeah typically and that's why
you go to other people it's something
like you know they heard something from
a company but it's they heard it a
little bit off most of the time it's the
companies themselves that will literally
lie to my face or you know try to spin
me in one direction or the other and so
one time I was reporting you know Mike
Judas I want to I want a good story not
a good story this is a good story so
well he calls me so Mike calls me the
Linkedin assassin because I'm always
reporting on folks from the crypto world
going to Wall Street or rather than the
way around people from Wall Street going
to crypto I think I reported on five at
least from New York Stock Exchange going
to coin base right which you know the
the assault just continues but so there
was one hire from a traditional Wall
Street firm really senior guy was going
to
really well-known cryptocurrency company
okay and so I had yet recruiters are the
best sources by the way because they
know where people are going and they
know for a fact that these things are
happening and so a really well-known
excuse me so a recruiter told me about a
very well-known guy making this move and
so I knew without a doubt but went to
the company and basically they said this
isn't true but you puts me in a tough
position because I have to think alright
I only have this this one guy who
without a doubt knows but they're
basically telling me this hasn't
happened and on this one I didn't go
with my gut I wrote this story but just
set it aside and said I'll wait and a
couple I think it was four or five weeks
later sweet way so you wrote the story
but didn't publish it and you like put
it in the drawer for later yeah because
I was only like 95% certain and if
there's that 5% uncertainty that's
sitting like in my a my gut right and so
basically I I went to the company I said
this guy's coming on is exposition is
what my source tells me and they said
well I mean we've talked to him we've
talked to a lot of people you know the
class of course in yeah but he's not
he's not hired right now so I was like
are you gonna hire him well no we may
not we talked to a lot of people and so
that level of sort of doubt was enough
to make me hold off for a little bit so
they end up someone at the company ended
up calling me four or five weeks later
saying that thing you were looking into
four weeks ago it was happening and so I
mean that's what confused me with when
we put out that that story on Goldman's
ambitions and everyone on crypto Twitter
store coming after me and saying oh well
the CFO said okay alright yeah we got to
back up insurance at this so you wrote a
story sure that said Goldman is I
believe your story said Goldman is going
to shut down or is not going to launch
the crypto trading desk that they had
previously said they were going to do so
that was that was what a lot of folks
have to take away people and that's the
takeaway people that
the story itself was a little more
detailed and and it was that custody has
moved up the line and the trading of as
a priority inside the bank as a priority
instead of the bank and the trading of
physical Bitcoin has sort of moved down
the list but their training obviously a
ton of different derivatives tied to
crypto and their trading futures
obviously and so I think a lot of people
interpreted the story is them completely
scrapping all traded all trading of all
types of crypto related assets which
obviously we did not report because
that's not true but I think a lot of
people interpreted that as being the
case and so the CFO basically of Goldman
said that that that our report or he
alluded to the report actually he didn't
really he basically said that this
sentiment is fake news and a lot of
people took that as meaning that my
report or Business Insider's report was
fake news so you wrote this report
everyone goes wild on Twitter you know
mainstream media people start trying to
correlate the story with the price
movements and so CNBC for instance they
reported that Bitcoin tanks 500 dollars
a coin after go after a business insider
report about Goldman's crypto strategy
when Bitcoin
tanked an hour and a half before any of
you know before our report went out and
so this just speaks to the the degree of
misinformation and I think when Mike was
on he spoke to a lot of these issues and
that's part of the reason why I'm
joining the block is to create and help
create a center hub for people to go to
where they can get out of this like
ridiculous misinformation chaos
absolutely to actually find some sound
reasoned news and information but but
what is it like when you write a story
and somehow it gets convoluted into this
thing and then the CFO of Goldman has to
respond and he says it's fake news like
what do you do do people start calling
you saying
like congratulations hey you screwed up
like what what is that response from
people and what do you do yeah I mean
what did I do
I mean I tweeted about it and I said
well this is exactly I was disappointed
in the response because it it he
obviously didn't read the original story
or he didn't frame his comments in a way
that said hey it's not just this one
report it's the sentiment out of it so
he wasn't necessarily precise but you
know I made the case clear listen you
know this is what our report said and
actually Marty said after the fake news
comment he said oh you know maybe
trading of actual digital assets has
moved down the list and customs become
more important our strategy might've
change which is exactly what the story
said got it
and so everything in this world as you
know emotions fly high and they and they
calm down and like oh we are not even a
week at a couple days in crypto is the
greatest human psychological experiment
we'll probably see in our lifetime
because not only is it all happening in
relatively real time there's a prices
attached to it and it's very very well
documented in terms of everything that's
being created online and that's what
makes it so fun to cover and and part of
the reason why I love writing about the
space originally what what really
attracted me to it wasn't necessarily
this any sort of political underpinning
you know there's a lot of libertarians
in this space wasn't a technology
underpinning there's a lot of really
smart computer scientists in the space
who loved the idea of putting a monetary
system in place that's coated the
impenetrable etc I mean it's insanely
groundbreaking computer science that
didn't attract me either it was really
the passion and energy and liveliness
and getting to tell stories for those
types of people that are unbridled ly
it's epic so all right so let's go back
to somebody tells you some sort of
information first story right there
and they provide you this information
and it ends up being wrong whether it
was malicious or not what do you do
after that story is either published or
you get you know kind of confirmation
that it was incorrect do you go back and
say to them hey you told me something
that was wrong
do you just drop it D burn them like
like what is there that the the response
to that I don't know if I've ever have
written a story that's been that's been
dramatically incorrect to the point of
having to go back to someone and and sit
down
ya know it's typically before the the
story will go live where someone might
tell me something that's inaccurate but
again you know I've never I've never had
a source really tell me something that
was inaccurate I have people sort of
dance around the truth you know but
that's just part of the job that's part
of the excitement you know and makes my
job fun you know it starts with someone
telling me something and having to fight
connect the different dots together and
it's typically in that process of
connecting the dots that you find people
being inaccurate or untruthful and all
of that typically shakes out before any
stories is up for sure um you know so
let's talk about a couple of things that
are happening in crypto because I think
you have a really interesting
perspective in that you get to talk to
all kinds of random people right
everything from traders to people legacy
firms to crypto natives kind of the
whole gamut let's talk about the ETF
right so ETS gotten a ton of attention
and seems like price goes up goes down
based around these applications
you know denials potential approvals
what's your take on you know does the et
have actually matter and if so what
would the impact be if and when it gets
approved I have come to the conclusion
that I think the ETF matters for the
space but it doesn't matter for the
price I think it doesn't matter at all
for the price I thought it did I thought
it could have a big impact but going
back a little bit to the run-up we saw
in December after futures launch I think
a lot of that was driven by this idea
that we'd have an ETF in a couple months
you know literally people thought that
all right we've been moving at a
breakneck
breck nick breakneck pace and it's going
to continue unabated and you know here
we are months and months later with no
ETF in sight probably won't get one in
2018 maybe not even the first half half
of 2019 there's a lot of work to be done
in getting that off the ground which we
can talk about but it's not gonna happen
now I don't think that's as important
though because when you look at the
crypto ecosystem as a whole and you
think about how much work we have to do
on the actual digital assets themselves
on scaling on getting a adapt on
aetherium or an EOS is actually used by
people not just 9000 active users a
month which i think is the the dap usage
or maybe it's a day on etherium we need
something that's actually scalable
actually as use cases not just for nerds
like us but for Grandma and Grandpa and
Iowa that they can understand I was at
token fest this past weekend and there
was a really cool company on one of my
panels and they're sort of trying to
position themselves as a decentralized
rival to Google and you know it's a bit
tangental but basically I asked him all
right why would my grandma care why
would my grandma want to stop using
Google to use this thing so she can get
tokens like that doesn't make sense to
normal people and we need to or those
companies rather need to make sense of
their projects to regular people and so
that's the impediment we need to get
over a a use case for crypto that makes
sense to the masses not an ETF and so I
think if we got an ETF tomorrow maybe
the price would rally a bit but I think
that's all gonna go down because you're
gonna think all right now regular
investors have access to this market but
it's the same thing as if you know you
have an amusement park this is a really
stupid analogy people tell me I'm really
bad at metaphors but I think this is a
good one it's like having an amusement
park with some cool rides that are like
different than other amusement parks but
they're not really there yet right and
so you have the ticket guy and they're
all just normal ticket booths you have
to go to the amusement park to get your
ticket and so an etf equivalent for this
amusement park is all right now
can buy your tickets online alright but
if you can buy your tickets online and
there's not that many cool rides that
excite you you're not going to go to the
amusement park likewise if you have an
ETF but there's nothing that you think
is that great about crypto or you don't
understand it right if there's still
that educational barrier you're still
not gonna invest in the ETF yeah it's
just it's changing the mechanism or
pathway to owning the asset it's not
actually changing the asset itself or
making it more valuable exactly and it's
not making it more understandable to
regular people you know you know there
are a lot of people out there that are
making really great that are doing a
really great job laying out how Bitcoin
could be the digital gold or a a rival
financial structure and other crypto
currencies and digital assets that can
also make major moves into chipping into
existing businesses whether it's data
storage or search but that get has yet
that has yet to be sort of deployed and
truly tested I think until we see that I
don't think an ETF will make a
difference and it's also ironic I think
that that we're waiting so much for Wall
Street to release complex derivative
products and and other things as opposed
to waiting with bated breath for what
what what's going on inside a theorem
and what's going on inside a lot of
these projects that's where I think we
should focus on our attention ironically
although I love watching the
developments come out of Wall Street and
this is something that I've sort of been
tackling with the past couple weeks
I think it's less important but it is
really it is important less important an
ETF is important for the in for the
ecosystem but I think it's less
important so ok so let's go from Wall
Street versus like crypto adoption to
the regulatory environment right so
there's all these like lobbying groups
working groups that are popping up that
are either led by Wall Street you know
executives or crypto native companies
individuals that are trying to bridge
the gap of understanding education for
regulators and lawmakers right are these
things good or they just doomed to fail
how do
you see that the working groups in the
lobbying groups actually having an
impact with the regulations and the
regulator's themselves so Mike Novogratz
had something really interesting to say
about regulators impression of this
space and I think it's really smart and
true and it's that what this market for
so long was so retail driven up until
the end of last year and while there
were folks at Wall Street firms looking
at it a lot of it wasn't public right
and so there was no you know back in the
housing crisis regulators could go to
their guy at Morgan or Goldman and say
what's going on on here with these
mortgage-backed securities and you
didn't really have that with crypto
because it was so retail driven and so
now they're playing catch-up they're
trying to figure this space out
they're giving it a chance though
they're not completely sending it off to
other countries as far as regulatory
arbitrage is concerned yep they want to
see development but there's a lot of
unanswered questions especially around
the ETF how can we make sure that these
markets aren't being manipulated and
when so much of the action is in is in
Asian countries so much of the volume
and turnover is in Asia and you don't
have market data sharing agreements
between exchanges you don't have a FINRA
equivalent you don't have you don't have
a guarantee right that that these
markets are operating along they're just
in a standardized safe way exact so we
yeah we don't know what best execution
is we don't know how we don't have those
market safeguards that we have in
equities but to be fair right equity
markets had 250 years to develop so it
is kind of like comparing apples and and
as lynn martin at ice said to me in an
interview once comparing apples and neon
florescent signs which is true and we'll
get them to be apples and apples
probably one day but but there's a lot
of questions that the regulators have
thrown to the crypto world and they're
not being answered so on market
nation if we can get the exchanges to
sort of cooperate and collaborate to
create an SRO which the Winklevoss is
Gemini's Gemini exchange has sort of
tried to spearhead with their their
working group that they've created but
you know you have coined coinbase
creating their own with circle and
Genesis yep right and I'm just here
thinking why are we getting them all
together it's just too much of a in from
my perspective it seems like the
Winklevoss Gemini exchange wanted to get
something that could help you know
because the regulator's wanted an SRO
type thing and so here they are there go
all right well create this thing to help
get their ETF on the ground and coinbase
probably season goes what we're not
gonna join you know we're not gonna
follow Gemini's lead we got to create
our own thing and it's just troubling to
me because we should all just be working
together right we should all be trying
to get to that common goal and purpose
which is sound markets creating the
standards for those sound markets and
educating market participants and not
market participants alike on why this is
a valuable space that you should put one
to five percent of your assets in
absolutely
so as this happens right we need
technologists obviously to build
technology standards et cetera and one
thing that I think you and I agree a lot
on is like there's a full-on assault by
technologists on Wall Street and
financial markets right the you know the
the Wall Street legacy organizations
institutions for a long time have
dominated that world and they do things
in a very specific way technologists
happen to think a little bit differently
build things a little differently and
kind of have a different set of ethos
and perspective and we're seeing this
clash right and it's really the
technologists attacking the financial
markets and the and the Wall Street
institutions how do you see that from
your perspective right as you talk to a
lot of all Street institutions like
what's their take on this what I think
is really interesting
if you want to look at something that
can prove or can support a bullish
thesis on crypto right now price
obviously is out
the argument scaling doesn't look as
great and there's a lot of issues but if
you want something that looks good look
at the talent assault look at how many
folks from traditional Wall Street I can
list them off have either dived into
crypto themselves or have been taken
from a Wall Street firm to the crypto
world you had a guy like Jimmy Selway
who left itg to be a head of
institutional development or sales and
not sure what the precise title is to go
over to blockchain right you have a
person like Christine Sandler leaving
New York Stock Exchange to go to
coinbase Eric's row from from New York
Stock Exchange went to coinbase Hunter
McGirt went from I think he was a sales
trader at arc please he'll probably
listen to this and tell me if I'm wrong
went to coinbase you had a guy like I
first reported 25 year veteran trader
who last was at Credit Suisse going to
Kraken for their OTC desk I mean the
assault is unreal and so you have to
think I mean there's they're probably
making great salaries right but there is
this this sweep that proves I think that
there is a vision that they see and
there is efficiencies that can be driven
by this technology and potentially maybe
even a revolution yeah I mean look it
forget all the money for except for a
second right I really do think that a
lot of these people are leaving because
they're going to something that's more
exciting more powerful and it's a global
phenomenon right and so the whole idea
of like the virus is spreading really
has become this thing of where the idea
of what it coined digital assets
decentralized finance etc has spread and
captured the mental energy right and and
it's a thing where once people get
exposed to it they understand it they
can't stop thinking about it they can't
stop trying to figure out how to solve
some of these problems do get inside of
an institution that's a legacy you know
Wall Street place just isn't gonna cut
it for a lot of them and so they've got
to go find somewhere else that's what
they're doing
totally but at the same time I mean you
see a company like ice launch back and
I'll tell you folks inside coinbase time
they think that's you know across the
crypto exchanges there they're not
chasing the competition in that respect
but they do see a serious competitor in
fact and and that's because you know the
trading market structure element of this
is so integral to building a sound
market whether it's you know crypto or
otherwise and so long story short you
see tons of institutional firms looking
at how they could break in whether it's
Goldman on custody Numair on custody ice
obviously on custody and potentially
trading and that's the story across the
street
absolutely now it makes complete sense
all right let's do some rapid fire
questions and then I'll ask you one non
crypto question that I've been thinking
about a lot and I'll let you ask me one
question after wrap it up what's the
most controversial thing that you
believe in crypto so the thing that you
believe that the most amount of people
when they hear it will disagree with you
I guess probably the etf thing I don't
think we should be worrying about that
as much as we do maybe that's not
controversial but I'm sure someone might
say that there's a good amount of people
that disagree with you everybody like is
obsessed with this ETF goodnight I'm not
obsessed with it all right be cool when
it happens Avery will probably argue
otherwise all about it okay so what is
the most important or interesting
company in crypto that people might not
be talking about that people might not
be talking about I reported on a fund
raised out of Chicago a company called
CCX and this this company is an
institutional platform for spot and
derivatives and they have hedge funds
knocking on the door and so what's
interesting about them one they raised
15 million in a bear market which speaks
to in a whole nother conversation about
how you know the public markets for
crypto whether it's icos or otherwise
really really bad but companies are
still raising millions of dollars yep
anyway what's interesting about them is
the majority of the firms are no sorry
not the majority but a large percentage
of the firm's that are knocking on their
door from the institutional side have
never traded crypto before yep which is
really insane and so clearly they've got
something going on there CFTC regulated
platform that I think is really
interesting and they have a a suite of
heavyweight X Wall Streeters a guy named
Sam Tegel who I first reported left jump
trading the he was recently brought on
and they got a really cool guy running
the show he's like 25 super smart and so
it's a company pay attention to : all
right man
we're gonna take your word for that one
you've got a magic wand and you can wave
it and change one regulation what do you
change one regulation that's I think I I
mean
we're probably on the same boat as this
I think the whole thing around the fact
you have to have 250,000 combination
accreditation laws I would I would bring
down a little bit I wouldn't eliminate
them I don't think but I think
especially someone who's younger and and
has some extra cash there's no reason
why a computer scientist at Harvard who
may not have 250,000 net worth shouldn't
at least take five grand and invest in a
venture capital project he thinks is
interesting I think that's absurd yeah I
mean look it and it's not it's so much
eliminating accreditation laws it's just
switching what the criteria is today we
have wealth as a signal for intelligence
which is ridiculous yeah and I've gone
on and on about this I don't need to
touch on any more but if we can go from
a wealth criteria to a knowledge
criteria I actually not only think that
one it is more inclusive of the general
population but two is actually probably
makes it less risky and a more sound
market because everyone is more
intelligent this is tons of people with
250,000 now were they were still volute
lis name like five for sure
alright so this is first of all I'm
asking somebody a non crypto question
but something that I've been thinking a
lot about and I just knowing you you
will have a great answer for this so
lots and lots of people are interested
around aliens right and let's let's go
ahead and just will say that yes there
is some sort of living organisms outside
of Earth so there's aliens somewhere do
aliens have pets so are there alien
animals
or they're just alien humans it reminds
me of that South Park episode where
earth is like a show or they put a bunch
of different species on one planet and
like you know we're all like going after
each other starting war that's eating
each other
joke's on us so maybe we're maybe were
the pets you think we're the pen maybe
were the pets
all right III I love that answer
I the way that it came up was we were
talking about aliens one day and I said
you know we always talk about aliens
like his human equivalents right they're
gonna show up and we can talk to him
hang out with them they might attack us
with whatever I said well what about all
the animals right and and is what has
that play they have animals yeah I don't
know but but maybe we are the pets or
the animals or the show yeah well we're
definitely a show I don't know who's
watching but we're definitely the show
all right so I let every guest ask me
one question what a what question do you
have for me that's a great question
well of course you know I have what um
what company do you I'd like to know
what company you think is the most
exciting right now ooh
what company do I think is the most
exciting I'm gonna break from Morgan
Creek yeah we take Morgan Creek out of
it I'm actually not gonna go the company
I'm gonna say that it is it's Bitcoin
right and the reason being I think that
people are bored by Bitcoin and I was
making the argument to a friend the
other day Bitcoin as an investment
opportunity Bitcoin as an economic you
know development Bitcoin as a kind of
you know a threat to sovereign backed
currencies et cetera it's too boring
right it's kind of come and gone in
terms of the excitement of Bitcoin and
so now we see everyone going into
everything from all of the kind of
derivative trading to you know what
while she wants to do two Enterprise
blockchains utility tokens I see there's
also other like fun sexy stuff going on
but if you go back to Bitcoin I still
think it's the most interesting most
important development in the space and
if it is successful right so it is a
complete binary bet in the sense of like
a true venture capital bet if it works
it is going to be insanely valuable even
from here if it doesn't work that's
going to zero right and so that binary
aspect of it scares a lot of people
right
if it does work it is probably the
greatest technological development of
the last I don't know 500 plus years
right and the the reason why I think
that it's so important is because it is
so simple right there's almost beauty in
the simplicity of Bitcoin and what it is
what it is trying to accomplish all of
the intellectual Olympics that happen on
Twitter and these other mediums they
kind of just skip over it right because
I oh yeah bitcoins a thing it was one of
the first you know applications and so
like let's go talk about everything else
then you know we're gonna try to figure
out well if you go back to that and you
really sit and think about out of every
single thing in crypto what has the
potential highest impact in a whole
different different ways you cut it it
coins still probably the most
interesting most important thing we just
don't spend as much time thinking about
that because of all the other sexy cool
things to talk about and that's why
we're here literally while we're here
man listen this is so much fun I really
appreciate you coming on and pleasure
and doing it on short notice and stuff
so what we'll have to do again
definitely
thanks so much alright thank you